i've been thinking about this a lot
especially since talking to richard
dawkins
it's like okay
the post-modernist types
going back way before dara dan fuco
maybe back to nietzsche
who i admire greatly by the way
he says god is dead
it's like okay
but nietzsche said god is dead and we
have killed him and will not find enough
water to wash away all the blood so that
was nietzsche he's no fool he's got away
with words he certainly does
and so then you think okay well we
killed the transcendent
well
what does that mean for science well it
frees it up because all that nonsense
about a deity is just the idiot
superstition that stops the scientific
what process from moving forward that's
basically the new atheist claim
something like that it's like wait a
second
do you believe in the transcendent if
you're a scientist
and the answer is
well not only do you believe in it you
believe in it more than anything else
because if you're a scientist
you believe in
what objects to your theory
more than you believe in your theory now
we've got to think that through very
carefully so your theory describes the
world and as far as you're concerned
your description of the world is the
world
but because you're a scientist you think
well even though that's my description
of the world and that's what i believe
there's something beyond what i believe
and that's the object and so i'm going
to throw my theory against the object
and see where it'll break
and then i'm going to use the evidence
of the break
as a source of new information to
revitalize my theory so as a scientist
you have to posit the existence of the
ontological transcendent before you can
move forward at all
but more
you have to posit that contact with the
ontological transcendent
annoying though it is because it upsets
your apple cart is exactly what will in
fact set you free
so then you accept the proposition that
there is a transcendent reality
and that the that contact with that
transcendent reality is redemptive in
the most fundamental sense because if it
wasn't why would you bother making
contact with you're going to make
everything worse or better
why does the
contact with the transcendent
set you free as a scientist because you
assume that you assume i mean freedom in
the most fundamental sense it's like
well freedom from want freedom from
disease freedom from ignorance right
that it informs you the logos in it of
science
it is definitely that
yeah it's it's the what it's the
direction let's say the directionality
of science that's a narrative direction
not a scientific direction and then the
question is what is the narrative well
it posits a transcendent reality it
posits that the transcendent reality is
corrective it posits that our knowledge
structure should be regarded with
humility it posits that you should bow
down in the face of
of the transcendent evidence and you
have to take a vow you know this as a
scientist you have to take a vow to
follow that path if you're going to be a
real scientist it's like the truth
no matter what and that means you posit
the truth as a redemptive force
well what does redemptive mean well why
bother with science well so people don't
starve so people can move about more
effectively so life can be more abundant
right so it's all ensconced within an
underlying ethic so the the reason i i
was saying that while we were talking
about belief in god it's like this is a
very complicated topic right do you
believe in a transcendent reality see
okay now let's say
you buy the argument i just made on the
natural front you say yeah yeah that's
just nature
that's not god
and then i'd say well what makes you
think you know what nature is
like see the problem with that argument
is that it it already presumes
a materialist a reductionist materialist
objective view of what constitutes
nature but if you're a scientist you're
going to think
well in the final analysis i don't know
what nature is i certainly don't know
its origin or destination point i don't
know it's teleology i'm really ignorant
about nature
and so when i say it's nothing but
nature
i shouldn't mean it's nothing but what i
understand nature to be
so i could say will we have a fully
reductionist account of cognitive
processes
and the answer to that is yes but by the
time we do that our understanding of
matter will have transformed so much
that what we think of as reductionists
now won't look anything like what we
think of reductionism now matter isn't
dead
dust
i don't know what it is
i have no idea what it is matter is what
matters there's a definition that's a
very weird definition but
the notion that we have you know that if
you're a reductionist a materialist
reductionist that you can reduce
the complexity of what is to your
assumptions about the nature of matter
that's not a scientific your specific
limited human assumptions of this
century of this week that
so in that in some sense
without god
in this complicated big definition we're
talking about
the there's no humility or
it's not enough there's less likely to
be
or rather science can err in taking a
trajectory away from humility well
without something much more powerful
than an individual human yeah well then
and we know you know the frankenstein
story comes out of that instantly and
that's a good story for the current
times it's like
you you're playing around with making
new life
you bloody well better make sure you
have your arrows pointed up
you